when Houston mayor Sylvester Turner took
a flight over the flood zone with the
city's police and fire chiefs he saw
entire neighborhoods still inundated
with water just before that flight may
have Turner spoke with mark Strassmann
in his first extensive interview since
the storm hit and mark joins us now from
Houston mark good morning to you good
morning the flood waters that have
receded in this neighborhood remain an
issue in a number of others the mayor
told me it's now time for him to focus
on this city's recovery to helping its
thousands of displaced residents like
these folks as he sizes up how Houston
dealt with this catastrophic storm every
one of these disasters is a learning
experience
and reminding me that you know Mike
Tyson said everyone's got a plan a Jay
get punched in the mouth city got
punched got punched hard
we've been punished before if anything
you wish you'd done differently no well
let me put it this way you can always
improve you know and we'll sit down and
we'll assess what we could have done
better city certainly doesn't need more
assets how water vehicles how water
trucks how water boats first responders
need more equipment and in a storm like
this when some of your roads are cut off
and your airports may not be functioning
at that point in time it makes it much
difficult to get to people as as soon as
you would like to you must be so tired
you've got roughly 12,000 folks and
shelters someone those folks are going
to need help indefinitely have
absolutely many of those people and
we're working on a plan for them to
transition them out what's the plan the
plan is to work with FEMA in the city of
Houston you've got thousands of people
that are impacted
we need a lot of female workers on the
ground registering and processing those
applications we need to be able to give
them the assurance that there is some
sort of temporary housing a permanent
housing for them you know people are
appreciative of being in the shelter but
after about five to seven eight days it
gets old it gets old and they want to go
home which means they expect us to
operate with the greatest degree of
urgency and none of this is gonna be
cheap what we are needing from FEMA is
an advance payment on debris removal I
will tell you my request has been
seventy five million dollars as an
advance payment just on debris removal
just for the city of Houston alone it
could be anywhere between 250 to 300
million dollars what's gonna be the
total price tag was going to be huge I
have the opportunity to do an aerial
view of the city of Houston any question
your mind that you'll be dealing with
something Harvie related to the last day
you're in office absolutely not you come
back and visit the city of Houston a
year from now and this city of Houston
will be a shining star of how a city
recovers when it has been hit with this
degree of anonymity there is no doubt in
my mind that the city that I know which
I was born in reared a city that I know
this city will bounce back like never
before
the mayor told me houstonians like him
have always faced challenges he grew up
as one of nine children to become the
mayor of America's fourth largest city a
graduate of Harvard Law School whose
parents never finished high school
he said the city will remain one of hope
and opportunity and come back stronger
than ever Vlad Houston's strong mark
Strassmann thank you very much for that
report